foreign
Vox has an urgent report this week the
headline from writer Alex Abad Santos
tells us quote people forgot how to act
in public which of course raises the
question when did people ever know how
to act in public what do you mean they
forgot did they ever know but we'll get
back to that in a moment here's how the
piece begins
some people shouldn't be out in public
right now movie theaters have become a
lawless land where some moviegoers Have
No Reservations about using their phones
after films have started sometimes it's
not just a glance at the time but
full-on social media Scrolls and posting
in New York City Broadway audiences are
drunk Rowdy and apparently leaving feces
in the aisles of theaters this summer at
various concerts Albanian uh pop star
Bebe rexa Bebo rexa is that what it is
was okay close up was being in the face
a fellow Pop Princess Ava Max was
slapped by a stage rusher an aerial
Enthusiast pink was handed someone's
mother's ashes fans interrupted country
singer Miranda Lambert's intimate show
with an impromptu photo shoot and a fan
through water on rapper rapper cardi B
cardi B responded by chucking her
microphone at her water flinger
large-scale in-person events are down
bad
Louise also note that a journalism is
down bad when the phrase down bad is
appearing in articles as for the rest of
it I haven't been to a to a concert in
probably 13 or 14 years I've never been
to a Broadway show and with six kids I
go to movies maybe twice a year at this
point which actually has less to do with
the six kids and more to do with the
fact that there are only two movies a
year at most that are worth watching in
the theater my point is that I can't
attest to the epidemic of bad public
Behavior at these venues
personally I haven't been around I
haven't been in these venues very often
but I don't I don't doubt the claim
and I'll also say that obviously this
should go without saying anyone who
Scrolls social media in a movie theater
during a movie
should be arrested on the spot and
publicly flogged if I were Theocratic
fascist dictator of America is one of
the very first policies I would I would
instate there would be public vlogging
stations set up directly outside of
movie theaters so that those who
misbehave can be dealt with quickly and
efficiently we would also have
Guillotines on spot for repeat offenders
and just to clarify for our big Tech
overlords who are listening to this
episode I am not advocating violence
against those who talk text or use
social media the movies I'm not
advocating it I'm simply suggesting a
legal policy
that we might want to explore
there would be at least one way to curb
the behavior that Vox is reporting on
and it's not just vox on the same day
the BBC published an article on what it
calls quote the summer of bad Taurus and
it begins quote this summer every day
seems to bring another headline of
tourists around the world behaving badly
last week it was two drunk Americans
sneaking into a closed section of the
Eiffel Tower and sleeping off their
Bender high above Paris the previous
week a French woman was arrested for
carving a heart in her initials into
Italy's iconic Leaning Tower of Pisa a
Canadian team defaced a 1200 year old
Japanese Temple last month just after a
bristol-based man etched two names into
Rome's Coliseum and told authorities He
was unaware of the Arena's age
and uh and who could forget the German
Taurus who crashed the performance
inside a sacred Bali Temple and stripped
naked after having previously run out of
the bill run out on the bill at several
local hotels feels like the whole world
has forgotten how to act in other
people's homes
so people are acting up in movies at
concerts on vacation at tourist
destinations
where else well of course we can't
forget airplanes which I've seen over
the past few years a stark rise in
incidents involving Rowdy and unruly
passengers 2021 was a very bad year for
that kind of thing and it looks like
2022 was even worse this past June the
International Air transport Association
released its official report on the
subject reading now it says quote the
International Air transport Association
released a new analysis showing that
reported unruly passenger incidents
increased in 2022 compared to 2021
latest figures show that there was one
unruly incident reported for every 568
flights in 2022 which was up from one
per 835 in 2021. the most common
character categorizations of incidents
in 2022 were non-compliance verbal abuse
and intoxication physical abuse
incidents remained very rare but these
had an alarming increase of 61 percent
over 2021. now
one incident every 568 flights doesn't
sound too bad on the surface but when
you consider the increase and also just
how many flights take off around the
world every day thus just how many you
know episodes of drunkenness and
physical abuse in the sky this
translates to
you start to see the scope of the
problem
and it's a problem that extends Beyond
airplanes and Beyond tourist
destinations and theaters and concerts
in many ways this is part and parcel
with the epidemic of violent crime we
talked about in the opening looting
shoplifting it's all part of the same
picture
and we haven't even mentioned the most
dire and Urgent indicator of social
chaos which is the fact that
as I talk about often nearly everyone
these days seems to have no problem
ditching their shopping carts in parking
lots
I actually looked for some hard data on
the rate of shopping cart ditching to
see how it's increased over time I spent
like way too much time this morning
looking for that somehow it seems like
this issue has never been formally
studied and I don't know how that could
be the case
all we can say then is that there are a
lot of people doing it
and everyone who has ever done it for
any reason
is a psychopath who should be in
solitary confinement
but the real question is why like why is
all this happening why are people acting
this way if outrageous offensive
anti-social behavior is becoming more
common than what explains the increase
well that Vox article has an answer and
it's exactly the answer that you would
expect it's the answer they give for
everything they say it's all because of
covid reading quote
according to experts I spoke to this
rash of bad behavior can probably be
traced to the pandemic shutdowns of
2020. during the lockdowns we didn't
have large-scale social events and no
doubt some people have sort of forgotten
how to act now that they're back since
humans thrive on Collective
effervescence it was a complete shock to
our systems in 2020 when the pandemic
seen me overnight obliterated those
social large social Gatherings finding
that in-person effervescence became
impossible the pendulum swung from
gathering in real life to being
relegated to social media to now in 2023
coming back to real life events May
explain why some people are being
disruptive and not fully comprehending
the impact they're having on their
fellow audience members they're using
the modes of social connection they got
accustomed to posting a video from the
movie theater scrolling through a social
media during a Broadway play or treating
a concert like a performance they're
watching from home in a setting that's
inappropriate
now to be clear I don't dismiss this
explanation out of hand there's no doubt
some truth to it when you lock people in
their homes and you shut down all social
Gatherings you force people to wear
muzzles depriving them of the ability to
see each other's faces and fully connect
even on the rare occasions when they're
out in public when you do all that
they're going to be social consequences
and none of those consequences will be
good a majority of gen Z supports
left-wing policies like open borders and
socialism if we don't reach them and
change their minds the country we know
and love will be lost forever those are
the stakes Prager you is the leading
non-profit when it comes to influencing
uh young people and I've been working
closely with Prager you for a long time
daily wire has especially and what we
know about prageru is that they have a
huge impact on the culture with
educational entertaining pro-american
videos where you can meet young people
where they are online and open their
minds to the truth but they need your
help to do it go to prageru.com and make
a tax deductible donation whatever you
give right now will be tripled and have
three times the impact donate ten
dollars or triples to thirty dollars
give a hundred dollars it explodes to
300 that's the math on that that's all
the math I can do prageru is 100 free to
everyone with no fees or subscriptions
they don't rely on ads or clickbait
headlines contrary to what the left says
prageru isn't funded by a handful of
billionaires it's funded by people just
like you in order to keep making great
content reaching million and changing
Minds prageru needs your help that's
prageru.com to donate today but this
doesn't come close to explaining the the
the a-hole epidemic or accounting for
the entire scope of the problem
the lockdowns may have exacerbated some
of this stuff but it was there all along
the real source of the problem the thing
that you probably aren't going to hear
anyone talk about on Vox
is that we live in a culture that
fundamentally encourages this kind of
self-centered Behavior
there has been a deliberate effort going
back decades to undermine and ultimately
destroy all of the basic standards of
etiquette that nearly everyone once
recognized
like they used to teach etiquette as a
subject in school but those days are
long gone
etiquette has become such a dirty word
that that you know Vox wrote an entire
article about etiquette and never used
the word etiquette in the article they
never acknowledge that that's what they
were talking about
what they're discussing is not just
people being quote down bad whatever
that means they're talking about a a
loss of etiquette in social situations
the problem for our culture and those in
charge of it is that etiquette both as a
term and a concept
first of all has the vibe of something
old-fashioned like our grandparents
cared about etiquette which makes it
automatically archaic and inherently
bigoted in the modern mind
etiquette by definition is a customary
code of polite Behavior among members of
a social group but customary means old
it means traditional
it means something that has existed
prior to yesterday
we and I'm by we I mean the universal we
not you or me specifically hopefully
we've decided that we have no use for
tradition which is why tradition has
also become a dirty word right alongside
etiquette
and that's what a lot of this stuff
links back to
second and more and most importantly
etiquette is a code of conduct
that you as an individual are expected
to abide by whether you want to or not
whether it feels good or not
whether it infringes on your personal
expression or not it is something that
is often supposed to supersede the
desires of the individual it comes
before living your truth whatever that
means
but as a society we've entirely lost the
ability to convey that kind of message
we don't even have the language for it
anymore
the feelings of the individual have long
sense take taken Center Stage
and they now come before any notion of
the common good or the needs of society
in other words people look at their
phones in the movie theater because they
want to look at their phones in the
movie theater it's what they desire to
do in that moment
it's what will make them happiest right
then and there they think
and uh so why shouldn't they simply do
what makes them happy
why should they care if it makes you
less happy
why should they concern themselves with
your truth
when they're so busy living theirs
the writers at Vox have no answer for
that
they can't really deal with this dilemma
because they don't understand what the
Dilemma is
we can complain impotently about people
being jerks but when it comes to
explaining why exactly people should not
be jerks it all breaks down
the only real solution here is to
restore some sense of order of
traditional etiquette of of social
custom it's to re-establish a hierarchy
where the momentary impulses and desires
of the individual are not sitting at the
very top in the place of utmost
importance
in other words it means defeating
leftism
that's the only actual solution
and we can be pretty sure that Vox will
not be up for that
which is why all the people acting like
jerks in public and also Vox are all
today canceled thanks for checking out
this video if you'd like to listen to my
full podcast on the go you can check out
the Matt Walsh show on Apple podcast
Spotify or wherever you get your
podcasts